one awful Progressive talk show host
quote joking about the victims not
praying enough that's supposed to be
funny I thought attacking one's personal
religious beliefs was not allowed in the
leftist woke world we live in yeah so up
on the screen is a quote by someone
named Kendall tits or she's Kendall
teets I have to admit I don't actually
know how it's How It's pronounced and it
says it's a quote from Kendall
Progressive talk show host David pakman
mocked the Covenant School Community for
not praying enough of course that's not
what I did I pointed out that prayers
don't work to stop mass shootings
Hannity can't even be bothered to show
the Tweet he just goes I don't know I'll
quote Kendall teets or Kendall tits what
the hell is wrong with these people